c'est parfait comme un treuil otc
squeeze aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour
une petite compilation de jeux sur
tablette
on commence donc avec strain langue le
jeu où il ya ces petites chansons voilà
monsieur ne connaissais pas ça vient de
sortir pas du tout ces partis alors le
but du jeu c'est simple on joue un
bonhomme en bois comme ça ça j'adore le
piano est au bord de l'eau puis j'ai vu
sur une base horaire d'écouté de toute
la truck touche le bouton rouge pour
faire bouger ma jambe gauche et bouton
bleu pour faire bouger ma jambe droite
ok bah là je les passais en même temps
c'est ni moins bon heureusement qu'au
racing - quand même il faille stretch
myfit forte houle longue maastricht
swiss ne voilà ce qui est marqué à peu
près dans ma tête
oh [ __ ] ok il ya des sacs de sable
mais on façon optimale aux quais des
gares d'ascenseur pas mal ok je vois
aussi des limites il y avait le talent
dans le vide quoi mais bon c'est passé
s'est passé c'était une talonnade et un
mode jeu de mot dans cette fan faut que
je fasse quoi au nickel un coup shot ça
s'appelle un os non aux avocats [ __ ]
c'est trop tendue aux soins qu'un petit
bug
oh oui merci le bug mon gars allez on
l'a passé et touche l'écran pour faire
bouger mon bras et je vais attraper ce
crochet obama a le même du coup je vais
rater à ce trop tard
au revoir à bientôt jetés raté mais
[ __ ] je t'attrape assez bon jeu les
oui oh oui oh mais non c'est un fait que
j attende les personnes chez mango qui
joue défonçant revoit au revoir je m'en
fous je tombe sur des petits piano mais
je les attrape le hors d'elle et il fait
comme ça tout autour de lui le mas allez
merci a bientot je m'en allais comme un
voleur en même temps pour le faire
sauter bah oui bah attends attends il
faut le faire sauter le machin est ce qu
il a une tête à pouvoir sauter
j'ai arrêté a confié ça ça fait plus
guerrier quand même c'est plus viril non
à ok d'accord mais j'ai tapotait la
beauce of town hall hubble elle est
belle elle est magique
le magnifique on va t'elle complimenter
jusqu'à neuvième tome 1 qui va arriver
et bien non en merde
oh oh oh les parties en mode pas le
temps a les atouts 8 complète mon gars
ben oui comment devient acteur comme ça
redevient un célèbre comédien ben voila
tu prends des coups de tête avec cet
homme ça marche très très bien pas il ya
un crochet mais pourquoi snop titane
adolescent vous avez un adolescent qui
paraît correct c'est vraiment pourquoi
achoppent le haut mais vas-y mais que
oui tu le shop online poker mais on lui
faisait du vent comme ça au revoir sacs
de sable arrêtez de faire à chaque fois
qu il y avait deux mutations comme ça
aurait à chaque fois que je peins pas
peu trop grand tout le monde s'affole
quoi oh bah oui à fermer notre gueule
pour qui se prennent cela osselets tac
prend la tablette serait pas content
pour la tablette voilà mais tu fais pas
tiens ça met la pression quoi merde et
sera compatible ou devant moi je
différents pas très fort
non je ne fais pas le suisse est très
désagréable
[Musique]
faut pas rater o o et nous avait une
femme et parce qu'il faut sur une grande
taille donc du coup bas pour maintenant
déplacements plus faciles act of
complète un hoquet nickel mais [ __ ] tu
es là vous demandais ce que je faisais
et oui ça gratte et des foyers des
endroits qu'il grimpe et improbable
savais même pas qu'il ya une partie de
ton corps qui est à cet endroit quoi ça
veut rien dire ce que j'ai à dire et on
s'en fout parce que paul n a de sens
dans cette vidéo d'accord alors nous
emmène au lui serra qui pendant 100 m
que crochet avant ce normal ah c'est
pour nous ni quel homme
mais non mais je te demande de sauter
padoue le soap et on pille on a compris
que ça marchait pas nickel nommer les
gars l'essai laissez moi le temps
mais cool et ne pas avoir un moment je
vais je vais te casser la jambe de voilà
on va appeler le menu sais tu vas voir
ce qu'il peut faire et trompe coupet ou
tu vas passer des trains d'une belle
statue en bois info kaka en boivent cei
dans les mains c'est bon j'ai raté mon
fond comme ça même façon qu on à faire
voilà qu'on en arrive à la auquel elle
est belle elle est belle elle est belle
on y va on y va s'aimer mais qd amis et
amis d'amis au cours d'un contrôle et où
nous et je peux pas dangereux mais comme
ça allait on s'en bat les steaks et ben
non je veux dire on va te rends toi
carrément on va si le mec avec le fils
allan walsh qu'à toi l'une à bourg même
dans les coulisses [ __ ] ça va bien
s'arrêter un moment au lasik salivaire
l'internet qui arrive après quoi [ __ ]
mais j'ai encore le syndrome du doigt de
pied je fais ça soit avec mes pieds je
suis comme ça et à sale temps mais sauf
si tu fais ça et là elle peut rien moi
je m'en vais de ce pas oh oui oh oui
trois étoiles a donc là on est bien là
on n'était pas bien potache et appelait
même s'en va mieux même mais si on a des
difficultés pour parler tout cela va
être bien compliqué à ces voix là encore
pendu ils s'attendent sauf son steak ce
jeu annonçait que ça va t'en sers un
[ __ ] il se cabre quoi ça je trouve
qu'ils expédient est pas fâchée que
l'autre ça qu'il est vers là haut mais
mais il m'a effleuré le doigt quoi mais
là ils cherchent à nous faire paniquer
ils savent très bien que la tension
monte et qu'on est de plus en plus il
faut pas leur laisser cette petite
victoire vous le savez je le dis souvent
il faut pas leur laisser croire qu'ils
ont
est-ce que et flore et la victoire par
contre tu avances mais mes voiles et
c'est ce que j'ai dit à l'instant il
faut pas leur laisser cette satisfaction
plat ils viennent de la voir là cet
espace là ils l'auront pas pour cette
fois uniquement 10 mai toi bien mais toi
bien joué les guides avec ta jambe n'est
pas de problème ok mais mais mais cott
non m'explique avait compté debout tu
fais pas ça quand tu attends alors aulas
attend mais laissez moi le temps 2 bah
ouais on a dit quoi nos moutons non sacs
de sable voilà howett custom ce mec pita
comme ça on pourra bien défoncé les sacs
de sable et surtout les tous nos gens
vident c'est le mode sans fin elle
laisse et aux fesses plan débat vous
avez quoi je suis bon on est maintenant
sur daddy l'onglet gsba et conseils sur
twitter celui ci j'ai des packs à ouvrir
là j'ai jamais joué mais j'ai des
bateaux gris c'est plutôt cool
vous n'êtes plus de pâques ht an oui ben
là petit pois ou si elle est pas mal
hop tap la hawla wa wa ou à tomber et
c'est quoi en fait faut avancer dans un
mec cigare moins contrôlable quoi enfin
un truc un moment où on y va comme ça
mais qu'elle est faible mais un tutoriel
ça existe ou pas puis kalou à la boj
veut juste un mec qui de ne pas dire la
musique d' inception mais en version bas
budget
hop là en fait c'est un coup hop c'est
ça ah ben ça trouve en fait les a mais
c'est plus sympa etc oui j'ai vite
parler c'est vrai en ohio
harry mail ot le cadeau toi ta grande
joie pour l'attraper comme sa mécanique
le kiff quoi il s'est fait un kiff tout
seul on était complètement exclue du
délire on y va on y va
tu vas y arriver tu vas y arriver tôt on
avait tous confiance en toi vas-y mais
tu fais quoi
annika will et il a feinté quoi on l'a
eue va l'ouvrir avec un plaisir inouï
voilà qu'est ce qu'il ya dedans il y
avait rien n'est calé derrière change de
joueurs à l'essai bon sens ni trop on
est maintenant sur traille regarder ces
belles animations des parties tap tap
tap et utah peut tapoter ils sont fans
et aussi de ça il faut que j'atterris ce
la musique qui te d'avoir l'impression
d'être le mec qui a fait un truc
exceptionnel
ah merde fait que j'atterris weir trahi
d'où le nom adore
du coup je suis un pilote après cette
danse est flic la bei qui te la ruche
regardez bien votre écran quand vous
jouez non mais non merci ou en eau
oui je sens que tu sens qu'il va dans
mon cerveau c'est très rare c'est très
rare mais là rien comme cela donc
effectivement regardez bien votre route
rail coffre jouer parce que vous risquez
sinon de voir quelqu'un qui a pas de
rupture comme ça on sait pas pourquoi ça
c'est beau mais ça que c'est quelqu'un
qui a son brevet bien sûr qu'a fait des
stages multiples attend mais la musique
est carrément nostalgique aux attendes
vis d'eux de t'envoler comme ça loin
avec ton avion
bon bah écoute eric raoult moment retry
ça va on va arrêter de rites rallier a
les deux pieds en fuite et prie pour
qu'il a alors allez on y va les gens
c'est la fin de cette vidéo sur ses
trois petits jeux bon plus le premier
que les deux autres est d'accord
j'espère que ça vous a plu 6 kasey kahne
et c'était pas beau mot à waziers pas
avait des baies la vidéo comme c'est le
cas en pire c'est de pire en pire il
faut arrêter là au centre savidan ces
nouvelles vidéos tient tout le monde pis
oui